من حقي أن أطالب ولا تأخذني بعيدا
والآن بيبروني أولبان أريد دولة إسرائيل
افعل كل ما لم أقل أنهم لا يفعلونه ولكن
في نتيجة الاختبار لم يفعلوا كل شيء وكانت هناك ساعة رملية
الذي ينفد وكل يوم نفقد شخصًا ما
فقدان شخص ما، نرى ما يحدث هنا
نحصل على نعش بعد نعش، جثة بعد جثة
اخبار سيئة
للجميع
ثانية واحدة أخرى للعيش
في العام، حذرنا جميعًا من أن معركة لولا ستسبب ذ
على شواطئ ليتزر
جانب
كان الشواء لـSharror Ho n
في غضون أسبوع، ربما، إلى جزيرة إسرائيل من حكومة إسرائيل
معنا اليوم واشرح لنا ما هو العرض الموجود
الجدول ود للولايات المتحدة سنوار اشاد يعرف
يجب على أولئك الذين يقدمون عرضًا أن يذكروا ما يتضمنه العرض من إطلاق سراح
غني بأيد مزيفة، سيقول شخص ما ذلك
بكل
بصوت عال لأن هذا هو ما
وهو أمر ضروري، إذا لم يعود طفلي وأنا في الحقيبة
بالتأكيد لا أحد منكم يريد رؤية الطفل
سيعود في حقيبة حتى اليوم، عليك أن تأتي وتعرضه
لا تعرض عليهم أن تخبرهم بإحضارهم بالحافلة
واحد إلى الحد الأقصى، وأنا لست خائفا من تحقيق كل شيء
الأغنياء في الحافلة ليخبروهم أن يأخذوهم
مازلنا مقيدين وسنطلق سراحهم ونأخذهم
وسيعيدهم جميعا إلينا صباح الغد أيها الصليب الأحمر
سيكون الأمر أكثر صعوبة قليلاً، وهذا ما سيحدث الآن
أعلم أن الكثيرين لا يحبون هذا البيان
أعتقد أنه فجأة بدأ الكثير من الناس في الحب
نفس الشيء في A Ag
ل لا لا سأخبرك بالضبط لقد سألت
أي أنه في اجتماع المقصورة قيل لي إننا نريد الاستمرار
لفوز آخر أردنا إطلاق المزيد لكن هامز انتهى
باسارب على حق، حسنًا، تعرف ما هو همس سام
ورفض لأنه لم يقدم بالضبط في الخطوط العريضة له
ذهب يريد الانتقال من الخطوط العريضة فقال رقم 10
نحيف
وقال سبع نساء وثلاثة رجال ودولة إسرائيل
قالت حتى الآن لست مستعدة للعب معي
وقالت دولة إسرائيل إنني لست مستعدة لقبول هذا الهراء
المختطفون الإسرائيليون لا يهمني ما هو مخططهم
لا يهمني من أي جماعة، فمن الواضح لنا جميعاً أنها حماس
سوف يلعب معنا ويتسكع معنا وإذا أخرج عصيرنا
نحن، نحن قادمون، نحن واضحون بشأن ذلك
مهما حدث، وعندما يحدث، ستذهب البلاد فجأة إلى الحرب
نعمت على قدميها وتقول لا وأنا
أعتقد أن الطريقة الوحيدة والفعالة لتحرير كل شيء
المختطفون من رحلة العطاء فقط للواقع الإسرائيلي
والواقع الإسرائيلي هو واقع مظلم للغاية
ومن ناحية الوعي، فإننا نستقبل المختطفين والقتلة
ما يسمى بالقتل نحصل على الجنود
قُتل نتيجة البحث عن الجثث
يستقبلون قادة آرا هيلي جولان وهم البوا
أننا نقتل في رمح الضرائب في التشابك
وفي نهاية الأسبوع حدثت مأساة فظيعة تتمثل في القتل العرضي الذي
من المختطفين لدينا وما إلى ذلك وما إلى ذلك
تتدحرج من مأساة إلى مأساة هذه الأمة من 7
في أكتوبر، يجب عليك، والسيد توقف عن ذلك، افعل ذلك الآن
توقف، افعل، فهم الاتفاقية تحت النقوش
لدينا يوم
واحد أن ينفق على هذا الشيء يجب علينا
يجب أن تكون هناك صفقة إسرائيلية بشأنها
الطاولة حتى نتمكن من إيقافها حتى لا يكون هناك المزيد
ذات يوم عندما نسمع عن المزيد من المختطفين
ربما يكون اليوم يومًا كثيرًا جدًا للمشاركة
من هذه القطط أنظر إلى أعينكم جميعًا
إلى الزعماء وأقول لكم